the trans Amazonian highway takes you
right into the rainforest the plants and
wildlife may have perished here but
there's also the indigenous people of
the Amazon what million of them
scattered across this burning wilderness
this village has been here for three
decades hello they're convinced that
this has been the worst year of
wildfires that they can remember Tom
they know that some of the fires here
are designed to scare them to make them
leave their land it is very sad our
ancestors fought for this land for so
long it is part of us it is our mother
some can forgive me we know that this is
a criminal fire that they don't like us
because we are the village that
criticized them the most and we are in a
fight we see ourselves as the resistance
in the next settlement down another long
bumpy track the fires got to within 100
yards of their home he told us when they
see a fire they just rushed to it and
try and beat it out themselves
so I then sold it the intention of this
fire was to get rid of us to leave us
without resources and food to the point
we'll have to leave our land and go to
the city and there we will suffer we
will starve the president of Brazil has
shown through his policies he has little
time for the indigenous people of the
Amazon and now he's rejected the 18
million pounds that the g7 world leaders
had offered to help fight the fires you
can throw money at this but you can't
rebuild the rainforest what has been
lost here is the biodiversity that lived
within it and that has been built up
over centuries it's all gone for the
people starting these fires that's not
their concern they just want more
farmland but the people who call this
rainforest home and who know this
habitat like nobody else well they're on
their own
Tom Parmenter Sky News in the Amazon
rainforest